cette porte est l'un des seuls vestiges
d'une histoire méconnue du musée stewart
elle témoigne d'un temps où des milliers
de personnes ont été emprisonnées d'un
bout à l'autre du pays en raison de leur
origine
ça a pris du temps long avant qu'on
parle de ce sujet là aussi le fait que
c'était un sujet un peu tabou lé donc
d'abord interné de façon massive de
façon préventive le sens qu'il ya eu des
crimes commis une si grande partie de la
population un total de 24 mille
personnes d'ascendance italienne
japonaise et allemande ont été
emprisonnés durant la seconde guerre
mondiale seulement dans l'est du pays
on compte neuf camps d'internement ici
sur l'île sainte-hélène 400 italiens en
provenance de l'angleterre ont été
infirmés entre 1940 et 1943
aucun d'entre eux n'avait commis de
crime mais c'était la crainte un peu ce
qu'on appelle la cinquième colonne donc
ce soient des espions que si jamais
l'allemagne envahit c'est la grande
bretagne se montrait compte la grande
bretagne
installé dans cet édifice les
prisonniers étaient constamment
surveillés par des militaires ils
occupaient leurs journées entre autres
en travaillant dans les champs
leurs conditions de détention étaient
moins pénible qu'ailleurs même s'il
régnait un sentiment d'injustice
c'est une époque on pense moi que la
guerre mondiale c'est quelque chose d'un
peu d'européens
donc ça se passe très loin d'ici avec
les call expert en trois ans se rend
compte en fait que ça se déroule aussi
juste à nos portes en fait c'est juste à
côté de montréal
une triste histoire qui a marqué bien
des familles ariane bousquet peut en
témoigner
son arrière grand père italien a passé
trois ans emprisonnée en ontario on n'a
pas vraiment d'informations sur son
passage à tabac voir et on sait que
quand il est sorti du camp ils étaient
beaucoup plus austère
ils en parlaient pas et c'était c'est un
homme très réservé
si pour ariane remettre à jour
l'histoire de ces prisonniers relève
d'un devoir de mémoire le musée est
ouvert et organise des tours guidés à
l'extérieur gratuitement à compter du 5
septembre pour parler de l'histoire de
ce camp d'internement ici marc isabelle
rochât radio canada montréal